khattak non pas du tout et c'est vous
non non tu as trop vieille vous êtes
peut-être de cela mais demander à ces
jeunes
est-ce que vous utilisez dicte oui oui
dans ma classe il ya beaucoup de gens
qui ont des tic tac
parce que ce sont eux les grands
utilisateurs de cette application qui
fait fureur partout dans le monde
une application de création de courtes
vidéos drôles simple efficace et
beaucoup de vedettes américaines y sont
présentes même les politiciens disent
ils commencent à s'y intéresser
mais aux états unis les sénateurs
américains la redoute
entre autres parce que la compagnie
derrière l'application et chinoises de
produits technologiques la menace est la
même qu'on parle de google maps ou de
tik tok ou d'instagram très difficile de
penser qu'un jour on va être capable
d'imposer une pénalité ou de poursuivre
en cours une compagnie chinoise tels que
tik tok collecte de données espionnage
des craintes aussi de censure d'ailleurs
la vidéo virale d'une adolescente qui à
première vue semble partager des
conseils beauté mais qui finalement
dénonce les camps d'internement des
ouïghours en chine a été bloqué son
compte suspendu temporairement après
cette publication
au-delà de ces craintes tik tok s'impose
elle a dépassé facebook et instagram
avec un milliard et demi de nouveaux
téléchargements et environ 50 millions
d'utilisateurs actifs
c'est sur quatre secteurs qui inquiète
les géants du web et facebook les infos
g you to me même probablement parce que
bell sont en croissance la quadrille el
mahdi dirige slingshot une agence qui
représente uniquement les influenceurs
comme kevin marquis
j'ai vu mr gottesheim fois du sketch
combres youtuber créateurs de contenu il
lui de sa présence sur les médias
sociaux
c'est tout j'obtiens des contres donc je
vois le même chose avec avec tik tok
puisqu'ils sont pas intéressants j'ai
fait une conférence récemment avec des
jeunes maisons de jeunes
j'ai posé la question il y en a qui me
suivent uniquement sur tik tok
véritable révolution ou simple feu de
paille est en train de traiter tik tok
comme les plus vieux traité facebook au
début la star toutes nos parents sont là
dessus tout aussi difficile donc de
prévoir temps l'expansion que la
pérennité de t4 et c'est jacques andré
charbonneau reste du canada
mon rêve
[Musique]